washington state has a new incentive to
get the wuflu vaccine
the state's liquor and cannabis board
yes that's a thing
is now offering marijuana dispensaries
the opportunity
to host vaccination clinics in their
stores and to give a free joint to
customers
who take the shot they are going to
incentivize you to get a shot
that ostensibly protects against a
respiratory virus
by giving you a recreational drug that
rips up your lungs
but the plan raises other questions if
the vaccine
is so great why do governments need to
bribe people with
money and food and drugs to take it
if the virus is so dangerous why aren't
people crawling over
one another to get the vaccine some new
moves by the public health bureaucracy
raise even more questions about what
we've been told and some top politicians
are finally calling for dr fauci to be
fired
now there is some uncharacteristically
good news out of the supreme court
and out of the pentagon that's great but
don't fool yourself
the left just proved it still has all
the power
i'm michael nolsus the michael north
show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday from trey best who
says
if jack dorsey doesn't like twitter
being banned
then they should just build their own
nigeria i totally agree
i absolutely agree that's why i'm so
happy that nigeria did what it did
you censor our president we censor your
stupid website i love that that's a
beautiful thing
now the fact of the matter is jack
dorsey does have more power than the
president of nigeria
and big tech as a whole you know not
just hipster rasputin
but the main oligarchs in silicon valley
very likely have more power than
conservative politicians in the united
states
almost certainly they do working in
concert with the rest of the blob it's
the sort of thing that could keep you up
at night
well you know why i don't stay up at
night because of my pillow
my pillow products do not go flat they
don't
i think you could probably roll them
over with a
military tank they would not go flat
okay
you can wash them you can dry them as
many times as you want they maintain
their shape
and they're made in the usa for a
limited time my pillow is offering their
premium my pillows
for their lowest price ever you can get
a queen size premium my pillow which is
regularly 69.98
for only 29.98 that's 40 dollars in
savings
kings are only five dollars more now is
the time to buy
not only are you getting the lowest
price ever they are also the best gifts
ever 29.98 for a queen size
premium my pillow i know a lot of us
love my pillow
because of the politics you know they
support conservatives so we support them
i would support my pillow even if it
were a communist company i would that's
how good the product is go to
mypillow.com click on the radio
listeners square and use promo code
daily wire
you will also get deep discounts on all
my pillow products including
the giza dream bed sheets the my pillow
mattress topper
and my pillow towel sets or you can call
800-951-7163
and use promo code dailywire that's
mypillow.com
head on over there right now or call
800-951-7163
they gotta bribe you with drugs and
cheeseburgers
and french fries and millions of dollars
through those covid lotteries
to take this vaccine that's apparently
so great that
nobody wants to take it because of the
virus that is so
so dangerous that everyone's just going
around
with their normal lives and many people
who have the virus don't even know they
have it
does that make a lot of sense to you i
don't watch a lot of professional golf
but i i read the news there's a golfer
john
rom john rahm is a spanish golfer he was
playing in the memorial tournament
uh he was doing very very well he was
leading the tournament
by six strokes man he was playing better
than any other golfer
in that game but now he's got to pull
out do you know why he's got to pull out
because he tested positive for covid
how do you know he tested positive for
covid well he just he took a test he
took an exam
you wouldn't know by his physical
appearance because not only does he seem
perfectly healthy
he seems healthier than all the other
professional golfers
but because he tested positive for the
kung flu
because maybe he has a cough even though
it doesn't even seem like he's got that
he has to pull out of the tournament
loses his chance at 1.6
million dollars 1.674 right now
maybe he can enter the covid lottery
where whereby states are bribing people
to take the vaccine maybe that's his
chance of making a million dollars
because he ain't going to do it
in this tournament this guy's obviously
fine
this virus obviously has
is a matter of what we can see as a
matter of what we can what he can feel
in his body no effect on him whatsoever
but we got to shut the world down for it
right we have to go get the vaccine
don't we it's almost as if
the virus is not as bad as the libs told
us it was i know we're not allowed to
say that
we're not allowed to say that right
because michael you know the minute you
say that sure
with our own eyes we can see that the
virus just isn't as bad as they told us
it was
and for those who have experienced it we
can feel
it yeah it wasn't as bad as they told us
it was in 99.9
of cases especially for people in the
healthy demographics
but michael six zillion
thousand million people died from the
virus right what's the number they say
the number is
nearly 600 000 i think in the united
states how dare you michael
that's so insensitive of you to make
light of a virus that's killed upwards
of 600 000 people
the thing is it didn't it just didn't
that number is
fake now i'm not saying that the virus
didn't kill anybody i'm not even saying
it didn't kill a lot of people
what i am saying though is it didn't
kill as many people as they said it
killed
and you know how i know that well one
common sense because we know we've had
these reports now for a year
that someone could get shot in the head
but if they are taken
to the morgue and they seem to have had
kovid
as they were getting shot in the head
that's counted as a covid death
and you know how else i know that not
only because
there was an incentive for over
diagnosis
given the way that federal funding came
out
but the way that i know with 100
certainty that the death number is lower
than what we have been told
is because even the public health
officials are admitting it now
the covid death toll in alameda county
california
just dropped that's wow are people
rising from their crypts
how my gosh how did the death toll drop
it dropped because
they redefined what a covid death is the
official total fell
from 1634 to 1223 on friday friday
because they they changed their
methodology here
so now this number includes
only people who quote died as a direct
result of covid19
or had the virus as a contributing cause
of death
or who for whom covid19
could not be ruled out as a cause of
death
okay that's a pretty broad definition
that's still
too broad as far as i'm concerned if you
have stage four
lung cancer and then you have or stage
four pancreatic cancer and then you get
covid
and then you die sometime later is that
really a covid death
i don't think so but according to these
rules it could be counted as one
or if you die and they don't really know
the circumstances but
you know you did have covid but it
doesn't seem likely that still could be
counted as one
so what did they take out well they took
out
uh people where they know
that kovid 19 was not the cause of death
okay they took out people who get shot
in the head but they have covet 19 and
previously they were counted as a covet
death
so here just more as if you needed more
evidence
more evidence that what we have been
told about this virus is not true
studies show and now the fouchy emails
prove that what we were told about the
masks
was not true what we were told about
risks to certain groups
not true what we were told about the
necessity of certain precautions
not true and even what we were told
about the death numbers not true this is
just one county in california
how many other counties in the country
would this be true for finally finally
finally
establishment politicians are coming out
and saying
enough is enough this thing is rotten
and we gotta
axe the head of this public health
bureaucracy that man's name would be dr
fauci even kevin mccarthy who
has done a pretty good job of keeping
the republicans in the house together
you know he's well liked by the
establishment but he's also not totally
alienated the conservatives
mccarthy just came out he said we gotta
oust fauci
does fauci need to go does president
biden need to fire him does he need to
resign
well the number one thing that has to be
for the american public does the
american public
trust dr fauci now that you've seen the
email
now that you've seen the flip-flop of
positions and
just now that he's requesting from china
to get the information
you've got to trust the individuals to
look into this hundreds of thousands of
americans
have died and if you've taken every
certain position in it
how are you able to come back with the
trust of the nation
to get to the bottom of it we have to
know
what went on and who knew what and when
i mean everything we're finding there
how can the president
and i know the american people don't
have trust in dr fauci
this is the key here when people do not
believe what the public health
bureaucracy is putting out
whether it's on the masks whether it's
on the deaths whether it's on the
lockdown measures whatever
when the american people are reticent to
get the vaccine which is true of
at least one out of every five americans
just don't want to get this vaccine
or these vaccines that's not their fault
that is the fault of the public health
bureaucracy if the public health
officials
and dr fauci is the prime example of
this if they had
even one tenth of one quarter of one
modicum of credibility left
i think a lot more americans would go
along with them
but they don't they've squandered that
because
they're incompetence and alternately
liars
and they have proven their incompetency
and they've proven their dishonesty
every single step of the way
now dr fauci is not taking this lying
down doctor
how dare you how dare you kevin mccarthy
question the exalted dr
fauci the high priest of secular
progressivism
if you question fouchy my
by golly you're questioning the science
it's really very much an attack on
science i think rachel
what is the thread going through what's
happening now is very much an
anti-science
approach so that's a big big difference
i mean it is what it is i'm a public
figure i'm going to take the arrows and
the slings
but they're just they're fabricated and
and that's just what it is but
we'll we'll just have to do our jobs
rachel
that's what i do all the other stuff is
just a terrible
not happy type of a distraction but it's
all nonsense
whatever the origin is you know there's
this concern is it a natural evolution
or is it something that happened out of
a lab an accident or wedding or what
have you
it is important to understand that but
it is being approached now in
in a very vehement way in in a very
distorted way i believe by attacking
me i think that the question is
extremely
legitimate you should want to know how
this happened
so that we can make sure it doesn't
happen again but what's happened
in the middle of all that i've become
the object of extraordinary
i believe completely inappropriate
distorted
misleading and misrepresented attacks
this question is completely appropriate
okay
but if you're asking it then you're
anti-science and you're a dumb idiot
stupid rube evil distraction this guy
this guy is everything wrong with
progressive politics
because he says look i'm i'm i am
science right i dr fauci am science an
attack on me
is an attack on the science now dr fauci
knows he's a politician
that's his job public health the health
part is the science the public part is
the politics
i i know that i'm a public figure okay
but it's a distraction to attack if you
don't want to be
answerable to the people then don't be
in politics but he's not quite in
politics right he's in
progressive politics he's in a sort of
politics where he is protected from any
accountability
to the people when things get as chaotic
as this
one wants to have something tangible to
hold on to and that's why i would
strongly recommend acre gold
you want a bar of gold but you don't
have a zillion dollars in the couch
cushions okay how are you going to do
this well
acre has the answer acre lets you
subscribe to gold bars for as little as
30 dollars a month you pay each month
and once your gold stash reaches the
price of their gold bars
they will discreetly ship acre gold to
your house
acre has a new 100 a month subscription
to a 5 gram gold bar
acre lets you invest in the physical
gold without coming out of pocket all at
once
i have really enjoyed investing in
precious metals specifically gold i find
that it's a good hedge when things start
to get a little crazy in the economy
and i enjoy investing in acre gold for
that matter i really like my my bar
of acre gold and hope to have more very
soon but you got to wait until your
stash gets up to that price it's just a
really great way
to start investing in precious metals
head on over to getacregold.com noel
start investing in physical gold today
make sure you
go to this url because acre is giving
away a gold bar
to qualify for the giveaway tweet or
post why you should be the recipient
and mention at get underscore acre that
is get acre goal dot com slash knowles
thank you anchor gold for supporting the
show dr
fauci declares that an attack on him is
an attack on
science and he is probably
unaware of the political insight that he
is giving us here
he's probably unaware of how much he is
revealing about
leftist ideology because i don't think
he's politically very sophisticated i
think he's a doer i think he's the
mechanism of this and we're
we here are the ones who get to analyze
it and figure out what it means
this is broadly the position of the left
it was true of marx it was true of
the progressives in the 20th century it
remains true of leftists today
they believe that their political views
are scientific they believe they know
the science of history they believe they
know the science of politics
and they believe that if you stand in
their way you are you are merely
impeding the inevitable flow of progress
and so
it's it's just a distraction whenever
people
are impeding their wishes that is an
unnecessary and
illegitimate distraction never mind
that their priorities change by the day
never mind that dr fauci has
contradicted himself
on the masks on the lockdowns on the
vaccine
availability on the origin of the virus
on the culpability of china he's
contradicted himself on every single
issue
doesn't matter whatever he says is
science and if you contradict him
that is illegitimate he can contradict
himself but you can't contradict him you
the people
you you measly little people and you
know what
there's nothing you can do about it
there's nothing there's nothing
that dr fauci can do that would get him
fired
to quote a great man to borrow a phrase
from a great man dr fauci could walk
out into fifth avenue and shoot somebody
in the middle of the street
he would not lose a single vote of
confidence from the people who decide
that he stays in his job
and those people are not the american
people those people are
the democratic hacks who run
our government namely joe biden
jen sachi white house press secretary
was asked this is there
any circumstance in which trump
or trump if only in which biden would
fire fauci here's the answer
since you mentioned dr thought you again
can you imagine any circumstance where
president biden would ever
fire him no go ahead um
just to follow up a little bit on russia
doesn't miss a beat
nothing a fouchy could do there is no
job requirement
there is no level basic level of
competency he needs to fulfill there is
no goal
that if he doesn't meet he loses his job
he
is the most powerful man in the country
there are many circumstances in which
joe biden loses his job
plenty and gensake and everybody else in
the government if
joe biden commits a high crime and
misdemeanor and we summon the political
will he'll be impeached and removed
if joe biden somehow manages to run
again the american people could kick him
out of his job
but not dr fauci because he represents
science if dr fauci is science
count me out i guess i'm i mean i'm not
one for the cult of science anyway
because i think it's it's pushed by
people who are extremely ignorant
of of the history of science and the
philosophy of science they don't know
what it is
that they are worshiping they don't know
what it is that they've made an idol out
of
but if it is fouchy if ouchi is the idol
count me out
why can't we
fix this why is it that this guy
fauci can totally expose himself for
what he is and i'm
i'm using him in particular but also as
a representative of the broader failures
of the public health bureaucracy why
can't we fire any of these people do you
know why
because we're not a serious political
movement on the right we're not
we're not the left is a serious
political movement the left
is very clever about politics the left
knows how speech works
the left knows how government works the
left knows how administration works
and they use it to their advantage and
they transform the whole
country i write about this at great
length in my upcoming book speechless
controlling words controlling minds
available now for pre-order at amazon
barnes and noble everywhere
and sign first edition from premiere
collectibles
the left is really smart and competent
at this and the right is completely
useless at it
i'll give you an example of how the
right is so useless so the right
in the last few decades has
absorbed libertarianism into it
conservatism conservative political
thought
and libertarianism are rather different
things
but over the past many decades actually
over the past
six decades or so the right the
conservatives absorbed libertarianism
that's at least what we thought we were
doing what actually happened
is that we basically just sold out all
of our political positions
for the views of libertarians and the
libertarians
of today the libertarian party i i
hesitate even to call them libertarians
because they would be such a shame
such a disgrace to the serious
libertarian thinkers with whom i have
disagreements but
they're far superior to these these guys
running around today
libertarian party of new hampshire amid
all of the craziness that's going on
lockdowns in the country people
uh being forced to close their
businesses people not being permitted to
travel the upending of our election laws
election integrity laws right out the
window
the libertarian party of new hampshire
decides to tweet out quote legalize
child labor
children will learn more on a job site
than in a public school
oh this is why this is why we can't have
nice things because
when we have every advantage when the
left has totally exposed itself as
stupid and corrupt and
pushing positions that are very
unpopular the
freaking libertarians decide to endorse
child
labor that's that's going to win
elections that's a resounding issue
right
child labor forcing eight-year-olds into
the factories yeah
that'll do it grabbing defeat from the
jaws of victory
it's not just this one cookie tweet from
one cookie libertarian party the
libertarian party of texas tweets out
quote
until we have open borders we can't get
rid of the welfare state
oh is that so oh the oh my gosh you
people you people
please give me the patience lord to
abide these very misguided
squishy lunatics
we're not going to get rid of the
welfare state anyway we can do things to
try to reduce
to reduce and minimize it but we're
certainly not going to get rid of it
it's just a pie in the sky it ain't
going to happen
but also you think the answer to
to this problem of the growing welfare
state and creeping socialism
is to um erase national borders
to take one terrible situation and then
add a much worse situation to it that's
the problem
the majority of americans including
democrats
want to drastically reduce not just
illegal but also legal immigration
and your answer when we've got totally
the upper hand in politics
is to endorse the least popular
political position
further to the left even of the
democratic party that's the that's the
libertarian party answer
reminds me of that libertarian party
debate do you remember this this was a
few years ago was it
maybe it was 2016. i don't really
remember maybe it's 2012.
whatever who cares it's libertarian
party presidential debate
my friend larry elder was moderating it
which was the highlight of of the event
and he asked a simple question should
should we have driver's licenses
here are the answers should someone have
to have a government-issued license
to drive a car what's next requiring a
license to make
toast in your own damn toaster
the license to drive you know i'd like
to see some competency
exhibited by people before they drive
oh my gosh any
any political movement that is going to
have any success
needs to forget this whatever this is
this first fellow who says a lice a
license to drive what's next
i i don't know it's like those have
basically always existed to some degree
or another you know and
i even if that were not the case even if
there were never any regulations on
driving
you know from the earliest days let's
say of automotives
is this this is a popular issue that's a
winning political issue
this is the matter of justice that we
need to fight
uh no no gary johnson
not not the most conservative guy in the
world he left the
the his governorship in new mexico to go
run a marijuana company okay he's not
and when gary johnson is the voice of
reason you know you've got a problem
with your party
there are many problems with this kind
of stuff it has
very little to do with the actual u.s
political tradition right it's not
conservative really at all it isn't
particularly just it's based on a false
understanding of human nature and
politics
but most important of all i really need
to drive this point home to the
republicans out there
this appeals to nobody okay this harping
on these
insane libertarian party
freshman year smoke up in your dorm room
and have a bull session
larping nonsense appeals to absolutely
nobody
okay you can if you look at the
political compass test right or if you
look at
sort of political surveys of where
people stand nobody
is in the this libertarian corner of
politics okay there are a lot of people
far in various regions of the left and
there are a lot of people
who are socially conservative and who
are relatively moderate
on broader economic issues but nobody is
in that corner okay
so when the right focus is on that
corner it's not principled it's not
dignified
it's embracing views that have very
little to do with american politics or
justice
that and this is the crucial point here
permit republicans
to be happy losers okay these are the
positions that
you can take that aren't going to offend
anybody they're not going to defend the
liberal state
because they don't threaten the liberal
state because nobody supports it
so everybody gets to say well look i
lost with dignity i hel you know it's
it's the
the squish wing of the party is
embracing these positions if we want to
win which i would like to win
i don't want to lose with dignity i
don't think the losers have much dignity
for that matter
then you've got to start embracing
winning
issues and you've got if you're if your
philosophy tells you that the most
important thing right now at this moment
is legalizing five-year-olds going into
the coal mines then you've got to
rethink your political philosophy
gotta check out today by the way ben is
gonna be talking about how for biden
being transgender is the new storming
of normandy this is a great another
great example of focusing on things that
are just so
preposterous but for the left there's a
point and it actually
does give them quite a lot of political
power go check that out today
we'll be right back with a lot more
i've harped enough on why the
libertarian party is
driving us to lose and lose and lose but
i want to show you the other side of
that
there was a correct column in the new
york times today
i know i hope man i hope you weren't
driving when i said that
so you might you might crash your car i
would say something so shocking and but
it's true
there was a good column in the new york
times ah i don't wanna say good
it was insightful it was accurate
headline
cancel culture works we wouldn't have
marriage equality
without it now one one reason this is a
decent column i think
it was a guest essay it's not from a
regular call there's no way that a
regular columnist to the new york times
could ever write anything insightful
but this is by sasha isenberg who's the
author of the engagement america's
quarter century
uh struggle over same-sex marriage and
it talks about the camp i won't i won't
read the
the column verbatim but it's worth
reading talks about the campaign to
redefine marriage
this was an extraordinarily uphill
battle
you have basically one definition of
marriage
for all of human history everywhere in
the world
and then you have this radical liberal
idea
according to the old definition of
marriage whether there was polygamy
whether there were various laws of
consinguinity or whatever
at the most basic level marriage
everywhere and at all times
essentially involved sexual difference
at the very least it had to involve men
and women together
right the radicals
in the last 10 years this isn't very old
in the last 10 years
came along and said you know actually
marriage does not have to do with sexual
difference what does it have to do it
has to do with romantic love well
romantic love actually
is kind of sort of new in in our notion
of marriage yeah well no it's romantic
love
but only between two people so it can't
be polygamous no it's got it it's just
between two people
it's a loving union well me and my
friend we love each other but we're
we don't know it's got it's a romantic
sexual anyway we're gonna redefine it
and if you don't hold this new radical
view that's existed for uh five minutes
now
you are a vicious bigot who has no place
in society
that's what these radicals said you
think there's no way this is going to
work
there's no way they put there was a
ballot proposition to define marriage as
it has always been defined but just put
it in writing in california called prop
8.
the the democratic base is the one that
shot it down because black voters did
not support this sort of thing
but then the left engaged in
cancel culture so the left went in
and anyone that voiced
any opposition to this radical
redefinition of marriage
saw their life destroyed you remember
this i mean
there are a number of examples in this
new york times column remember it was
brandon ike the the guy who started
mozilla
he donated something like eight hundred
dollars or a thousand dollars to the
prop 8 campaign because i don't know
he's is he christian or he's
conservative or whatever you know
this is the view that has been held by
statistically every single person
throughout history so it's not
it doesn't seem like a radical view to
say men and women are involved in
marriage
his life was destroyed he was booted
from his company and this sent a message
he said oh
if we hold these views now the views
that everyone's always held we will
just we will lose our livelihoods okay
so people stopped holding the views and
now
now it's worked if you if you question
this
you you will be destroyed unless unless
your job
is in conservative politics and by the
way even if you work in conservative
the view that i'm expressing right now
is a very unpopular view
among conservative political
professionals i think if you polled
most most people who are in elected
office in the republican party
or who work as staffers for politicians
or even who work in the conservative
media i suspect
the majority of them support this
radical redefinition of marriage
so even here there's no guarantee that
you're safe
i mention this not because of the
marriage issue that's
actually not what i'm interested in at
the moment i mention it because i'm
interested in cancer culture
because cancel culture does work because
this new york times columnist is right
and conservatives once understood this
and we once were the enforcers of cancel
culture
and that was a good thing now the
current line from the left
from the right rather i think we're high
on our own supply here in the
conservative movement
is that we say that cancel culture is
strictly a left-wing phenomenon
and it's always evil and it's always
terrible because it's a violation of
free speech absolutism or something
and now it's so ironic because
we we don't engage in this stuff you
know but what the left is doing is
they're behaving just like
joe mccarthy and mccarthyism remember
anti-communism in the 1950s and you said
wait a second hold on i thought you said
conservatives never engaged in cancer
culture but now you're comparing cancer
culture
to that very famous example of
conservatives engaging in cancer culture
which now you're saying was terrible but
which i'm saying was
awesome it was great it was there were
flaws with it because joe mccarthy was
politically
not not very adept particularly toward
the end and he kind of actually
undermined anti-communism but that's
just a tactical matter it's not
a question of the rightness or wrongness
of anti-communism the point is
there will be standards we once knew
this there will be taboos there will be
things
that you can't say there will be things
that you can't do
in the 50s that was waving the communist
flag
today it's waving the american flag
those are the taboos
and we give up
on the enforcement of standards at our
own peril
if we will not present a positive vision
we cannot win this is by the way you may
have heard me mention this
the thesis of my upcoming book
speechless controlling words controlling
minds
i guess this thesis is very
controversial on the right i guess right
now
the right is basically saying the
opposite of this thesis
that the current squish conservatives
are insisting on the exact opposite
of my view which happens to be correct
but that's why we keep losing guys
that's why if we want to win we need to
take a step back
maybe put down what the joints that they
gave us in washington state
maybe put down the ideological joints
that we've all been puffing on for the
past few decades
stop getting high on our own supply and
say wait a second
maybe the slogans of the past 10 years
the gop talking points maybe they're not
eternal truths
maybe conservatives of era's past have
something to say
maybe gosh maybe even the left
understands something
maybe we can learn from them so we can
start winning like they do
that would be nice we have so abandoned
our standards in this country
that we cannot even say definitively
that it is wrong
for women to be forced to fight our wars
for us
the the supreme court just
came out and
punted on the question of drafting women
there was a case brought up
they said is it constitutional to
prevent women from being drafted if you
had asked this question
10 years ago certainly forget 50 years
ago or 100 years ago 200 years ago if
you'd asked this question even 10 years
ago he said
hey is it a constitutional obligation
that women
be forced to serve overseas and fight
our wars for us
you would be laughed out of the room on
both sides of the aisle
but today we've become so
obsessed with this idea of exact gender
indiscernibility i don't even want to
say gender equality the idea that men
and women are exactly the same
which by the way is the logic not only
of transgenderism but also of the
redefinition of marriage and also many
social movements of the last
several decades that the right has
bought into from the left right we have
we have unfortunately adopted their
talking points and their premises
so now as the inevitable conclusion of
this we're going to
have to go draft women ship them over to
vietnam and fight the vc i guess we're
not fighting that war anymore we're
gonna end up shipping women to the
middle east
and we're gonna convince ourselves that
that is right and just but it's not
right and just
it's simply wrong and it's wrong
because men and women are different and
men should protect women
because women are the weaker sex this
was not a controversial statement
anywhere at any time until five seconds
ago
but we are s we are living in such a
separate ideological fantasy at the
moment
such as such a fantasy that we believe
men can become women we believe that
bruce jenner is a woman now
such a fantasy that we believe babies
aren't babies
such a fantasy that we believe that men
and women are exactly the same and women
should be shipped overseas to fight our
wars now
i don't want to leave you in total
despair
there is some good news coming out of
the federal government
actually some good news coming out of
the supreme court there was a question
brought up to the court
do illegal aliens have the right
to a green card now
you see if if illegal aliens
have the right to a green card then we
have
by judicial fiat completely abolished
our national borders right
if foreigners have the right to certain
privileges
of americans
there's no border there's no border
whatsoever
thankfully i know you never hear this
out of the court
there was a unanimous decision on what
could have been a controversial issue
it's it's not controversial as a matter
of the law but it is controversial as a
matter of politics
in a nine to zero decision the supreme
court ruled that a law
barring illegal immigrants from seeking
green cards is
constitutional and that those illegal
aliens
who later earned temporary protected
status are still
ineligible to apply for permanent
residency and justice elena kagan
who is one of the courts more left-wing
justices but she's smart at least
unlike some other justices in our
nation's history and present
uh elena kagan really is a sharp cookie
scalia apparently liked her you know
kagan wrote the opinion of the court and
said no this is a step too far guys okay
good
finally there's some recognition of
standards but if you asked your average
leftist on the street
you said hey do um
illegal aliens i'm sorry future
future undocumented americans whatever i
don't know what the current euphemism is
people who are much more american than
anybody else in the country you know
that fellow from guatemala who doesn't
speak a lake of english
that guy you know he who crossed the
border illegally
does he is it legal to bar
him and prevent him from seeking a
green card most leftists on the street
would say no that's deeply unjust
deeply unjust you need to permit you
need to give him amnesty tomorrow but
thankfully the supreme court at least
has pushed the brakes a little bit
same thing is true with the defense
department so you remember this the
state department came out
and they said that embassies around the
world now are not just going to fly the
american flag or the prisoner of war
missing an action flag
they also can and in some cases are
encouraged to fly
the rainbow flag the pride flag even at
the vatican seems a little disrespectful
to me
so i pointed out that the pride flag is
really not
no it's no longer just a representation
of sexual desire
that's what they want us to believe it
is but it's not it's a representation of
progressivism
uh it's a representation of american
empire
because the american flag is a symbol of
the united states which is a real
country with real people with real
borders
but the rainbow flag is a universal
claim the rainbow flag
is just as true in tunisia as it is in
the united states right because it's
making claims about
human rights most broadly actually the
same is true of the black lives matter
flag
which is why the left favors those flags
because those are universal
imperialist flags rather than a specific
national flag because the left no longer
believes in nations
so the defense department came out and
said that they will not permit
their bases to fly the pride flag and
they were very cautious about this the
the
spokesman john kirby said
uh this is in no way reflects any lack
of respect or adver admiration rather
for the lgbtq plus community
this was really more about the potential
for other challenges that could arise
from that exception
and this is this is my point too this
actually isn't about
the sex stuff i don't think that's
really what this is about at all i think
this is about
supplanting the american flag redefining
what flag symbolizes our country
for the left today the pride flag
symbolizes the country that they want
much more so
than the american flag does and it's a
it's about keeping the door
closed to what would happen if you put
the pride flag up then they're going to
demand the transgender flag then they're
going to demand the black lives matter
flag then they're going to demand
the antifa flag for goodness sakes
they're going to be flying the isis flag
by the time we're through
that is some good news that at least for
now the brass at the pentagon has put
the brakes on this sort of thing
but the elected officials not quite not
quite there
you remember we pointed this out
yesterday joe biden
on the anniversary of d-day very
important event
to our nation's glory wonderful day to
remember our nation's greatness
uh ignores it instead he focuses on a
race riot in tulsa a hundred years ago
that nobody remembered until very
recently and the reason they didn't
remember it is it's an
unfortunate fact some historians i'm
sure remembered it but because
it was not important to our national
self-understanding and the left wants it
to be
the left wants to forget d-day as our
national
identity and they want to remember this
horrible thing in tulsa
so jen he was asked about this she won't
give an answer
presidents bush obama and trump all
commemorated
d-day anniversaries on d-day on the
d-day anniversary
why didn't president pine well i can
tell you that certainly the
uh his value for the role that men and
the men who served
on d-day uh and the memory of them uh
the families who have
kept their memories alive over the
course of years on this
day is something the president has spoke
to many many times in the past
it's close to his heart and i wouldn't
be surprised if there's more
we would have to say on it i wouldn't be
surprised if there's more we would have
to say later
after the anniversary and you know the
president keeps these memories of the
families and his
huh what what's that babble there's no
answer the answer is no answer
no answer whatsoever because they just
want to ignore it
because they want to reframe american
history and focus on something
else speaking of
barack obama and donald trump
it was an excellent question from peter
ducey peter ducey asks shinsoki you know
obama
obama and trump very different
politicians they both recognize d-day
but joe biden isn't right now and
the reason that joe biden wouldn't
recognize dj is because he wants to move
on
he wants to move on to the next
progressive thing so speaking of obama
and trump
barack obama was just asked about rising
anti-semitism
right anti-jewish attacks
who do you think he blames i'm gonna
give you a hold on i'll give you five
seconds
you only one guess who do you think he
blames oh you got it you got it it's
trump
he believes that trump fanned the flames
of anti-semitism
quote when i gave that speech it was
clear that anti-semitism was on the rise
around the world
people's anger over everything from
immigration to inequality was boiling
over
and many of them were looking for
someone else to blame and for four years
we had president of the white house who
fanned those flames you know it's
my obama's a little weak my obama and my
boehner kind of bleed into one another
those are sort of slurred and emphatic
i would remind you when we're talking
about the
anti-semitism of donald trump
there is a town in israel named after
donald trump
there is a train station in israel named
after donald trump
bibi netanyahu i think is going to erect
a gigantic statue of donald trump as law
if he gets to hold on to power in israel
donald trump was the most pro-jewish
pro-israel president
donald trump's son-in-law is a jew a
practicing jew
donald trump's daughter converted for
the son
son-in-law there has never been
a more pro-israel pro-jewish president
in american history
barack obama a very anti-israel
president
very pro-palestine very pro-iran
president
and he just says these things and
forget about the israel issue for a
second or even forget about trump this
is the problem to me
the left can just say things they can
say things that we know
are not true and then when they are
proven not to be true we can call them
out for it and they will
look us right in the face and they will
say don't believe your lion eyes
don't believe your lying ears and there
will be no consequence
they can get away with that because they
have political power
and they know how to wield it and we
don't and so we can we can be
self-righteous until we're blue in the
face we can say oh
i was right i was right well okay cool
being right and one dollar and fifty
cents will get you a cup of coffee
in politics if you do not have the power
you can't do anything about it
which brings me to a poll that just came
out from hill staffers
these are all the legislative aids all
around capitol hill
78 of senior capitol hill aides
believe that republicans will regain the
house in 2022
this is up from 12 in april who believe
this according to a poll from
punchbowl news it just came out
yesterday
now i guess it's likely i suppose i
would say it's likely that republicans
retake the house
but i want to ask you do you think that
the republicans are going to retake the
house in 2022
i i suspect a good number of you are
going to have the same answer i have
which is yeah i think we'll retake the
house
if the elections are fair am i allowed
to say that am i allowed to
make that caveat i don't know if i am
maybe we'll see if hipster rasputin
and the rest of the oligarchs let me say
that you know the the
oligarchs who defend our democracy which
in in the words of angelo coudivilla
means that they're oligarchy
because i don't even know if i'm allowed
to say that presidents of the united
states are not allowed to say certain
things
shows you about the fairness of our
elections
it is indisputable that in 2022
lots and lots and lots of election
integrity laws laws that even barack
obama until very recently said were
essential to election integrity were
thrown out the window
and the excuse for that was the
coronavirus
the coronavirus of course uh being the
thing
that the liberal establishment has lied
to us about
ceaselessly for over a year now
but that was the excuse to do it and
they changed a lot of the rules and
there were lots of
irregularities and in some cases there
was the outright violation of state
constitutions
like in the case of pennsylvania
if the elections are fair i think it's
there's no question that republicans
will take back the house
this is just what happens in the
midterms when one party wins the white
house
the other party tends to win the house
if the elections are fair
the the house and the senate right now
are trying desperately the democrats in
the house and the senate are trying
desperately
to rewrite the election laws even
further and make their
changes permanent why why is that hr1
s1 why is this the first thing that
they're trying to do
that weird why that emphasis because the
vi the virus
theoretically i guess is going to go
away people are going to get vaccinated
right so you're not going to have the
excuse anymore
of the pandemic to change all the rules
so why are they now trying to make this
permanent
if this is all above board and totally
squeaky clean
because maybe maybe it's not speaking of
our representatives i got
there's some good news actually out
right now elise stefanik who is the new
uh gop caucus leader jiffy
conference leader rather in the house of
representatives announced that she's
pregnant with her first child
so that's great for her congratulations
to her i'm really glad to see this
uh you know it's not an earth-shaking
news story
but i'm glad to see it because i like
when our leaders walk the walk there's
this weird phenomenon in europe where
heads of state in europe
don't have any kids and look not
everyone gets to have kids and that's
a sad fact and it's very very hard thing
to go through infertility and that sort
of thing
but i think a lot of them are choosing
not to have kids i think a lot of them
are deciding that they don't want kids
and it's very strange when you would
lead a country if you have no stake in
the future of that country
or in the future of that civilization so
good for elise stefanik
uh also worth pointing out some of you
have have written in about this
we had a mailbag question last week that
a lot of you have written to me
uh there was a woman who was
contemplating abortion and a lot of you
wrote in and said
that you would you're you know a stable
couple and you'd love to
adopt this child and um uh you know
here's some resources and all this and i
just think that's that's really uh
terrific i'm really
i think it kind of proves the point
which we keep saying like look
you don't need to choose abortion uh not
not just for this one woman who wrote
into the show but for
women in general you don't need to what
the left tells you that you need to do
it it's going to
destroy your life if you have this baby
just not true many many more people want
to adopt babies
than there are babies to be adopted um
you don't need to just even believe the
statistics we've proven it on this show
so uh really great stuff um uh
i guess just one more example of uh what
the left is telling you
what the left establishment is telling
you through tech through media through
the administrative government
it's just not true makes you really
question
all of the messages they're putting out
there about just about everything i'm
michael knowles is the michelle show
see you tomorrow
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boary
our technical director is austin stevens
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
production manager
pavel vadofsky editor and associate
producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coromina
hair and makeup by nikka geneva and
production coordinator
mckenna waters the michael knowles show
is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire dailywire2021 today
on the pen shapiro show president biden
salutes the bravery of transgender
people
but not the veterans of d-day on d-day
that's today on the bench bureau show
give it a listen